we do not have the pink cards for people
to uh
indicate they wish to testify but I it
was rummaging around in the other room
and I found pink you had a phone message
things and since they're pink I'm going
to declare their pink cards for the
purpose of this meeting so if you would
like to testify you can
um just put your name and a brief
description of your topic and fill it
out and pass it up if you would
okay while you were sleeping we had a
palace coup and the chairman of the
subcommittee decided he wanted me to be
chairman of this subcommittee and and
he's older than me so I agreed
um this is the subcommittee looking at
transparency in the reporting of
complaints against Physicians that's not
the technical term that's all I can
think of without going through my papers
what I'd like to start with is the
minutes from last time and
um
I'll tell you how I did it I wrote like
crazy and then wherever somebody gave a
testimony
uh I sent them that section of my draft
not so that they could give additional
testimony but just correct errors and
omissions and I got things back from
various people so the second version of
the minutes
um
we have you were sent them the end of
last week you should have hard copy in
front of you if you're on this
subcommittee and I'd just like to give
you a few minutes to go through again we
don't uh update the minutes in the sense
that things have happened over the
weekend but we want to get as clear a
description of what was said as we can
so if you see errors or omissions
um
this would be the time to bring them
forth
share recognizes uh erstwhile chair
Solway
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
the adoption of the Minnesota's
distributed
you're taking the trains yeah
do we have a second
um yes representative
and I just had a question um no I'm
going to receive a second and then we
can have questions and discussion I'll
second it all right give a second now
your question uh there was a couple
statues mentioned in here I think should
have been statutes I didn't know if you
wanted to change that at all on page if
we're referring to
um 3D release of famous figures their
statues if their laws their statutes so
uh where in the on page three uh
representative Weber asked Dr Conway
about a statue
we note that it was violated so we hope
it's a statute thank you and number six
on page number six on the um the statue
regarding bom is permissive says statute
I don't even want to change that
and where is this again Page Six
where uh third or fourth line down the
statue regarding important medicine
you do know at my one of my day jobs is
don't you I do not well we'll tell you
afterwards that's why my default is to
Statue
representative Edwards uh first I I
don't know how you did it Mr chair uh
chairing the committee and taking notes
and producing them it's just incredible
I I think Oxford is proud of you uh and
I would just point out a small thing
that I think on the last page of written
material it says that division three of
Finance is responsible for Health and
Human Services matters I I would
substitute the word resources for
matters
resources yes sir you you do matters I
do resources
and you think it matters
and uh
counselor you have a correction yes
thank you Mr chair um during our last
meeting during Dr Baker's testimony I
would
happen to my mic I was taking notes
myself and I noted something very
important to me at least and I was
wondering if we could amend the minutes
to reflect the statement but during her
testimony Dr Baker uh was pointing out
that very few claims were actually
worthy of discipline and she made a I
believe page eight would be the most
appropriate section
oh she was she was this was while she
was disgusting um not having the tort
system driving evaluation of medical
practitioners and she made a comment
that discipline could create stigma for
doctors who have and I put in quotes
learned their lesson and to me the
statement is ambiguous and we didn't
follow up on it and I thought it was an
important enough statement to amend the
minutes to add it
first of all tell me first of all please
tell me where on page eight you would
like an insertion
about halfway down there's a line that
says mention was made of the Federation
of State Medical boards fsmb okay uh
what do other state boards do how much
do we want to yield to legal system in
the process
um the statement was made according to
my notes around the time of of those
questions
and would you repeat slowly please I
actually wrote it down I can repeat it
but I also wrote it down when you wrote
it down when you now say it would you
again say it slowly please sure
discipline
so this is my own statement discipline
could create stigma for doctors who have
in quotes learned their lesson end quote
this is a tribute does anyone else
recall anything like that being said by
Dr Baker from the Board of Medicine I I
actually do recall the phrase I don't
understand what it's it's significant
you want it in there I'm just curious
what your interpretation of that is I
think the language the term learn their
lesson is ambiguous enough considering
we're talking about transparency uh it
might be worth following up and maybe
getting seeking clarification from Dr
Baker at some point as to what she meant
by and learned their lesson because we
it was in the context of not
disciplining a doctor
as I recall that part of the
conversation she was dealing with an
area
around you know maybe maybe the notes
weren't done on time or maybe the notes
were incomplete it sounded to me like as
I recall that she was dealing with more
of the administrative functioning of
being a doctor as opposed to the
clinical decision making is that the way
you remember it
oh
did you say that again I'm not quite
sure I understand oh okay so she was
going through the layers of reasons that
the Board of Medicine should get
involved and and there was a section of
what position Behavior may be that could
create some interest uh such as uh poor
note keeping or late note keeping you
know the documentation and the medical
record those sorts of administrative
aspects of being a good physician as
opposed to the quality of the medical or
clinical decisions being made and I
think the reason she said well they've
learned their lesson if they get
prompted to to to do more timely medical
records keeping than that could be
handled without it becoming a kind of a
public thing that could hurt their
reputation that that's the way I
remember that
yes representative Weber please
I can shed some light on that too
because I think it was my question
because I was kind of appalled by the
statement that somebody could have
violated a statute
and not receive discipline and so I
think I asked the question
what on Earth
give me an example of somebody who had
violated a statute yet would not receive
discipline that sounds like a pretty
bright line to me and the example she
gave was what you were talking about
somebody who did not keep their notes as
legibly as people would like and and her
point was you know that's something that
yes is is actually contrary to the
statute but a word to the wise is
probably going to suffice as opposed to
as you say a clinical
issue that
needs far more discussion and and
perhaps corrective action thank you
all right yeah I remember something like
that because certainly there are minor
things and if we read up everybody who
made a mistake uh other than the ones
here uh would we wouldn't have anybody
doing anything anymore but there are
major things such as clinical errors
that are should be inexcusable
ah
so that's a good clarification
anybody else on the minutes
so it was moved to accept the minutes
but should we amend the motion to amend
the minutes uh given the updates that
we've suggested here
I think I think representative Solway
needs to amend his motion if we do this
well I would do amend as described and
with the second agree okay
so we would amend at this place and
everywhere I type statue instead of
statute
two of which have been already noted and
there may be others but wherever okay
anything else
all of all in favor of accepting the
minutes as amended please say aye aye
opposed thank you
here's what I hope we will do going
forward and this is after consultation
with my immediate predecessor as chair
uh
he has prepared a emotion
it will go to
the joint
Department of Health and Human Services
oversight committee which meets on the
28th
out of which this subcommittee was spun
and oversight we'll take a look at it
and have a go at it and we'll discuss it
and whatever and some of us here are
also on oversight so we'll be there
and out of that possibly could come in
LSR
now I realize this is a rush but I
didn't invent this schedule
and an LSR could come out of oversight
but we will have a couple of months to
amend it and my guess is any bill that
comes out would go to Edna
and
we will have a couple of months from the
LSR coming out
uh before Edna would work on it and that
way it could be tweaked it can be
whatever and an amendment could be
offered at that time
so while this is for the next few weeks
I'm going to be rushed what we produce
possibly out of oversight is not the
final work product
okay
um I'd like before we present your
motion representative I'd like to hear
from anybody who wishes to come up to
testify briefly and for that the chair
recognizes attorney Holly Haynes who has
eight pages of her testimony
so if you would like to come up please
and there's one very important
requirement of testifying here do you
know what it is
turn the mic on yeah
yes sir thank you chair
I have brought amended copies of my
testimony since the last hearing thank
you very much for Speed allowing me to
speak today by the way because I had a
conversation with David Lowenstein the
chair of the National Practitioner Data
Bank after this hearing and he clarified
one point that was included in my
testimony and I wanted to make sure that
that was corrected for the written
record
I have several copies I don't think I
have quite enough for everyone in the
group but I'll pass them around what I
have
and specifically what
um Mr Lowenstein informed me was that
his website the National Practitioner
databank's website was incorrect and
they had incorrect information on which
I was relying I believe that my
testimony said that New Hampshire was
one of Nine States out of compliance and
he has since fixed the website and New
Hampshire is no longer reported as out
of compliance on their website so I just
wanted to correct that for the record
um speaking with Mr Lowenstein though I
was able to get a lot of additional
information about
the reporting requirements for the Board
of Medicine and are for the National
Practitioner Data Bank and what
information the Board of Medicine in
fact receives we heard a lot of
testimony at the last hearing about
the board can't do anything if they
don't have the information that was
something that we heard I think from
several of the witnesses and according
to Mr Lowenstein at the National
Practitioner Data Bank under federal law
all insurers whenever a medical
malpractice payment is made it has to be
reported to the National Practitioner
Data Bank within 30 days federal law
also requires that that report be copied
to the applicable State Board of
Medicine so the State Board of Medicine
receives it at the time and they always
have that information it's just whether
or not they choose to publish that on
their website we know that Massachusetts
does we know that New Hampshire does not
um
as we also learned at the last
subcommittee
hearing oplc director Lindsey Courtney
testified that
nothing is done nothing is made public
at the Board of Medicine unless
discipline is imposed I think that's one
of the biggest failings in the
transparency that we need to address
at the same time at the hearing the
former chair of the Board of Medicine
David Conway testified that often
violations of the disciplinary statute
are bound but no discipline is imposed I
think in those cases it also is
imperative that that be made public
because the public has a right to know
when there are violations of the
disciplinary statute
um
since this hearing we had a meeting of
the New Hampshire Association for
justice medical malpractice group as
well so we could discuss potential
Solutions or suggestions that we had for
proposed legislation and my
recommendations from the prior hearing
stay the same I think we need to
increase transparency by reporting all
medical malpractice payments paid by our
on behalf of this position all
reciprocal discipline that's imposed by
any other state all formal complaints
that are founded and investigations that
are conducted and the findings and how
those complaints are disposed of I think
that should be public especially if
they're bound not to be founded a
physician should be happy that they are
I guess exonerated on the website by
stating that a complaint was filed and
it was bound to have no merit or not be
founded
um the second is by protecting the
public and changing the manner that the
disciplinary proceedings happen I think
that's probably one of the bigger issues
that needs to be addressed
um
Emily Baker and David Conway will
testify that link I think it was pretty
clear that the board does not have the
funding and they don't have the
bandwidth and they don't have the time
to provide meaningful discipline to
positions
they're a volunteer board they're made
up of volunteers I believe their
testimony was that it takes years
sometimes just to get through complaints
they provided some conflicting testimony
Dr Baker said that every complaint as a
formal investigation Dr Conway said that
many complaints are found to be without
merits so they aren't investigated
complaints that seem to have Merit
receive a formal investigation so there
was some conflicting testimony I think
what was clear from this though they
need funding Dr Baker alluded to it
would be helpful if they had funding to
send complaints to out-of-state expert
witnesses to in the applicable specialty
so they can review complaints for
Barrett because New Hampshire is such a
small and insular State all doctors know
each other and it's hard for one doctor
to pass judgment on another doctor that
they may see at Society meetings or in
their own Hospital
the Board needs funding for that they
need as the Director said funding for
the website they need
one of the suggestions that our group
for the New Hampshire Association for
justice came up with was creating a
system similar to the attorney
discipline office
which is a formal disciplinary
proceeding it's not made up of
volunteers there's a paid lawyer who
screens all complaints that come in
screen some against the statute review
some for sufficient evidence then
there's a formal investigation and
there's a Prosecuting lawyer and there's
a hearings panel there are several
different steps but they're all formal
and they're paid employees they are not
volunteers so they're people whose job
is dedicated to solely
reviewing disciplinary complaints and
investigating them and imposing
discipline when warranted I think that's
something that everyone in our committee
thought might be helpful and one way the
attorney discipline system is funded in
New Hampshire which we thought could be
replicated under the Board of Medicine
is we pay and administrative fee
just to be admitted to the bar of the
state we pay a fee for attorney
discipline we pay it every year at
annual renewal and our fees fund the
prosecuting attorneys for the discipline
the attorney discipline office that's
something that could be added to
physician licensing fees and it would
provide funding for a more formal
meaningful disciplinary system at the
board and that would allow also for the
funding for the website public reporting
and increased transparency
these are just some of the suggestions
that we came up with
um I think first and foremost the
purpose of this committee was
transparency so the reporting
requirements is the most important there
are several ways that the reporting can
be done first when the board receives
the report from the National
Practitioner Data Bank that a payment
was made the board can add that to the
physician's licensing
page on the website they can do that at
the time it's received they could do it
annually at renewal when they're
renewing the positions license because
they are looking at the data Bank to see
if any payments have been made they
could do without licensing or they could
pay an annual query fee for all
positions in New Hampshire this is
something else that could be done
according to Mr Lowenstein States vary
in their processes that there are many
states in the nation that do just pay an
annual query fee so they can receive
reports on all of their positions each
year other states do it just at renewal
and other states do it just at new
licensing but the process is vary there
is a procedure there and with a query
fee the state of New Hampshire could do
that annually and they could have that
information to make public and finally
the
complaints that we were discussing at
the last hearing
I
the trial lawyers understand and I I
think I explained at length how many
inquiries we get to our office that
don't have Merit it would be cost
prohibitive to bring it's not a claim
that we would pursue and we couldn't get
expert support for I'm certain that many
complaints of the Board of Medicine are
similar there are people who are upset
because they had a really bad medical
outcome but it doesn't mean that
malpractice happened those are the types
of complaints that probably could
receive an initial screening and not be
found founded but anything further than
that if it's something that has been
filed in court the mandatory reporting
by the superior court that happens I
think that's something that should be
publicized because it's been found to
have at least some Merit enough to file
a lawsuit the
whenever an insurer makes a reservable
claim they have their mandatory
reporting to the Board of Medicine that
means an insurer has reviewed it
internally with the medical expert
there's enough Merit to it for the
insurer to reserve money to make a
payment on the claim so it means they
think it has some Merit if a hospital
credentialing committee makes their
mandatory reporting it means that
positions on that committee have found
at least some Merit to the claim those
are the types of complaints that I
respectfully submit should be put on the
board of medicine and whatever the
outcome of the investigation happens
whether it's bounded whether it's not
founded whether discipline is imposed or
not that should be made public as well
and finally
one thing that we did discuss is that it
seems the Board of Medicine has very
differing treatment and how they treat
complaints we heard differing testimony
from doctors Conway and Baker we also
know just from our experience as trial
lawyers experience that our clients have
had that
complaints that come from patients do
not receive the same
rigor as complaints that come from other
doctors or complaints that come from
hospitals and there is specifically
there's one
doctor specifically On The Board of
Medicine who was reported by his
employer and received discipline it was
a
750 dollar fine and a restriction on
practicing
multiple patients made individual
complaints about that position as well
and some before the employer made the
report those were dismissed and they
received they received a letter saying
that the board wasn't going to take any
action then the employer reported the
exact same conduct for the exact same
patient's case and the board did look at
it and do an investigation I submit that
that treatment shouldn't be it's the
exact same conduct the exact same
position the exact same patient it
should have been treated the same
following that discipline additional
patients complained about the same
doctor and received letters stating the
board's already looked at this we've
already imposed a fine we aren't going
to consider your complaint now the
problem is the scope of the misconduct
was so Broad and so many patients were
impacted a slap on the wrist because of
one employer report I don't think is
sufficient it's something this is a
position that also should have lost his
license since long before that happened
and long before those complaints came so
that would be my other suggestion and
that comes from our association that we
make sure that the board treat
complaints from patients take them just
as seriously as complaints that they
receive from other Physicians and other
hospitals and I'm happy to take any
questions you may have
yes uh representative Solway uh thank
you so much uh councilor Hanks do you
have an electronic copy of your
testimony that you can send to me I do
can I give you my card sure thank you
I have a question
um
in the
story about The Physician at CMC the
surgeon
my understanding has been that neither
Eminem morbidity and Mobility or the
credentialing committee made a formal
complaint but docked individual doctors
from that facility did
and so I'm finding it I I have a gap I
guess in my understanding as to why the
Board of Medicine didn't proceed did
they
it wasn't a clerk of a court it was an
insurance company it wasn't a hospital
committee but it was Physicians and so
why do we not hear of what action was
taken next it helped me
um you can't read their minds but I
think I may have a gap in what I'm
understanding and I'm not familiar with
what Physicians did report to the Board
of Medicine I think it would be much
more helpful in Physicians that were
involved in that process were able to
testify to that because I don't know I'm
not familiar with those reports or what
the board knew I don't I do know that
the Board of Medicine had several formal
lawsuits that had been submitted by the
superior court against that position
over the years that they could have
looked into
presumably therefore that the clerk of
the court passed that information on to
them as he or she is required they did
and so the board did have at least that
information
and I believe that the board was
provided with additional information on
many other cases but did not take action
does anyone else have any questions for
attorney Haynes representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair I I think I it feels
like I have three different things
um uh in your in your testimony you said
that there was conflict between Dr
Conway's and Dr Baker's testimony
regarding whether or not investigations
are done all the time and as I recall
the feeling that I had in during that
meeting was that
neither of them were keyed in on the
specific language in the statute on
there being informal investigations
versus formal investigations and so so
as I interpreted the differences between
their testimony I I chalked it up to
probably just speaking different
languages about what constitutes an
investigation and not and not a conflict
as much as they're just speaking to it
differently is is is that fair or do you
still believe that their testimony
collected that may be a fair inference
I'm the way I heard the testimony is how
I just testified because Dr Baker did
say that all complaints receive a formal
investigation so I I think that was the
difference it could be semantics and it
could be and an unfamiliarity with the
statutory language I'm getting older in
my memory stating I I I understood her
to say that they all were at least
received an informal investigation that
way they could determine whether or not
there was Merit to go to a formal
investigation or not maybe I wanted to
hear that because it made sense to me
but so I don't know what she said the
the before you go into your next Point
representative Weber you wish to speak
to this point
yeah I think it was
um and again I my memory is imperfect as
well and my
understanding comes from my background
which is as an attorney and
um at least when I was practicing in in
Vermont there was
an initial screening which would not
have been called an investigation but a
complaint was filed uh an attorney for
the board would read that complaint
um and one would get a a letter marked
personal and confidential which was very
worrying when it showed up in your
mailbox uh saying would you care to
comment on this
and uh that happened to me once and I
did
and then they made it clear that nothing
that had been stated in that complaint
actually arose to accla an actual claim
of malpractice there was nothing there
there so there was a screening process
first which and and I think we may have
gotten caught up in the semantics of
screening versus
formal versus informal investigations
and perhaps that's an area that needs to
become
clarified a bit
any anyone else on
this point
you may go on to number two all right
um all right so
thank you for your written testimony you
made I think an outstanding point about
a potential way of maybe augmenting the
resources of the Board of Medicine and
use the comparison to the what the
attorneys do and I'm in the written
testimony here I'm not seeing that
description am I just missing it is that
in your written testimony because it's
such a good idea we may want to steal it
essentially word for word
I don't know that it's their word for
word in the written testimony but I did
make the suggestion of creating a
tribunal a prosecute a separate tribunal
outside of volunteers where you have
Prosecuting attorneys there's a limited
description in there but I did not
include the suggestion about the
physician licensing fees to fund it as
the attorney licensing fees fund the
attorney discipline office okay for for
our for our clerk if if you've got
something that's easy to copy paste you
know or it'd be great because I think
we'd want to look at that I'm happy to
submit something additional and then uh
as I was listening to your testimony
you're very disciplined like a good
lawyer as you had you know sort of your
bullet statements and I was trying to
follow along on your on the bullet
statements inside your testimony and and
I couldn't correlate them and it's
probably just me not
focusing properly but do you do you
think all of the bullet statements that
you made that for your recommendations
are actually in this written testimony
or do you believe you're you verbally
augmented what you wrote I believe I
verbally augmented what I wrote Because
I know that I did not include the
position licensing fee portion in the
written testimony I do know that that's
not in there I believe that everything
else that I discussed is contained in
the written document though just maybe
not in the same detail okay thanks I'm
such a bad clerk when I do it I just
need as many uh training wheels as I get
so but thank you for that
representative Murphy uh thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for your
testimony again
um my question is
when you refer to the attorney
discipline office that you referenced
before the process seems to me to be
similar to what happens in the Board of
Medicine currently where I think it was
Dr Conway who was an investigative
physician for the medical review
subcommittee of the board actually did
the initial screenings and if it reached
a certain threshold then it was brought
to a full board meeting to see if it
actually had Merit and my question is is
that how it is done with the in the
attorney discipline office that you have
do they do an initial screening that is
then referred to a larger board group uh
among the attorneys
I do know and I'm sorry that there's
something blocking yeah I do know that
there is an initial screening but the
screening is done by a paid uh there's a
screening a complaint attorney who
actually does the initial screening and
does
um look for evidence or violation of the
statute that's the initial review and
recommends prosecution then there's a
separate prosecution attorney so it's
not a volunteer position I think that
the difference and this may be one of
the difficulties with the board is that
everything at the board of medicine is
volunteer so you're relying on people
who are volunteering their time who may
not have the time or the resources to
devote to
doing I'm meaningful screening
any further questions nope saying none
thanks so much for your testimony thank
you very much
I don't see any more pink important
message pink card substitutes
um is there anybody and you just haven't
filled it out and brought it up
saying none
then the chair recognizes the clerk who
has a s a draft of
a possible statement to go over to
oversight committee that meets on the
28th
if I may take a moment Mr chair to pass
these out do you have winter I do
you have one second
episode
thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen
um I think we can hold off for a minute
because I find whenever I hand things
out they'd rather read them than listen
to me and that may be true for you too I
don't know you're a professor
um
that should be here
foreign
representative Weber
well I realized that representative
salivaay said that he would give us a
moment because he
knew that we might want to read rather
than listen to him so if he would like
to make a statement first that's I would
defer but I have some comments when when
he's finished
representative Solway uh thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for your
patience representative Weber
um the document that you have before you
is a draft it is not a draft of an LSR
it is a draft of a recommendation
to the oversight committee uh for Health
and Human Services that it developed on
LSR
pursuant to its own preferences however
the draft that I've provided is offered
as a beginning step
only a beginning step
it begins with the sense that uh
any organization that employs a
physician within the state
will uh convene in timely fashion
internal review committees and hospitals
certainly do this but other
organizations that employ physicians may
or may not this would provide a
statutory requirement that they do so
these committees are typically called
variously and some organizations have
all of these
some have won some have not
credentialing committee morbidian
mortality committee tissue committee or
complaint committee and these are the
mechanisms by which organizations that
employ Physicians review the performance
of their Physicians
in the course
of these deliberations
this recommendation goes on
these internal review committees will do
their own investigation
and we would assume that they do that
already
and in any case in which
an internal Review Committee finds what
it thinks to be a lapse in professional
practice
and in which it recommends disciplinary
action keep in mind this then removes
from discussion those investigations in
which disciplinary action is not
recommended
and in which
and in which that disciplinary action uh
directs the limitation or suspension of
physician privileges in order to protect
patient well-being
the organization the employing
organization is required to report this
disciplinary action
to New Hampshire Board of Medicine
now this is in no way this in no way
contravenes does not affect in any way
the standing provision that the clerk of
superior court reports to the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine any judicial
finding of malpractice which comes
before it and results in the finding of
malpractice this is a different issue
entirely
the Board of Medicine shall then
investigate the disciplinary action by
the Health Care Organization
that has resulted in limitation of
suspension of Privileges and will then
consider its own actions appropriate
within its Authority
to regulate physician practice
now in order to do this the Board of
Medicine is going to need resources
and so the Board of Medicine
shall seek that I'm disciplined I must
say by attorney Haynes uh review of uh
practice among attorneys uh I think
that's a good idea but here it states
that um the Board of Medicine will seek
such additional funding
uh in the budget process to staff its
responsibilities
to remunerate volunteer positions for
travel and and this is an issue that
arose in our discussions with the Board
of Medicine and to make known to the
public by means of appropriate media its
findings and the board has indicated
that they need help in developing the
website in order to do that so that's
built in here as well as you look at
this you will note that this is crafted
in a series of stages it is not simply
oh hospitals need to report in fractions
it is if there is a report and if there
is an investigation and if there is
disciplinary action then that gets
reported to the board and then the board
assumes responsibility for its own
investigation and its own disciplinary
actions so it's a staged response
to the complaint
uh and now I'm looking forward to
representative Weber's
critique and so am I
thank you for the work on this
um because I think it's encapsulated an
awful lot of what we've talked about so
far
I would not
um frame it as a directive to draft an
LSR with the following Provisions
because I think it's more a list of
issues or consideration by the oversight
board some of which would not in my
opinion actually be part of an LSR
in particular the the final one the
Board of Medicine functioning is a body
of volunteer professionals shall seek
such additional funding as is necessary
um I I think you can either
ask somebody to
um draft a statute about how such a
board is going to come into such a
how such a position is going to come
into
effect and how it's going to be funded
but I think that's something that the
legislature has to draft and consider
after appropriate public comment rather
than directing another organization to
come up with that so that's that's
that's the kind of Distinction I'm
thinking about it's something that I
think definitely ought to be considered
but I my real my only real concern here
is is with the second paragraph which
says
um
recommended that the oversight committee
submit to the House of Representatives
and the Senate Aid directive to draft an
LSR with the following Provisions I I
would say something more like
the oversight committee consider it the
following issues in considering
legislation I do think that the two
pieces that I think are very important
and and certainly there can be tweaks
down the road but I think setting out
clearly that there is going to be some
kind of oversight
without
directing what it is and my my nitpicky
thing about paragraph three is if you
say such committees may be constituted
as credentialing morbidity and mortality
tissue or complaint committees that
you're limiting it to just those and you
other
organizations that
employee physicians may have different
proceedings so I think we're in one of
those conditions where you say you have
to have some kind of
review but you don't tell them
specifically and again that could be as
simple as saying
including but not limited to the
following uh where and then maybe the
words were appropriate because you know
I don't really know about
freestanding entities of various sorts
and how they deal with those kinds of
reviews so
um again that that might be squishier or
or not
um I I think your point about what has
to be reported I'm this was something I
was trying to get at when I was asking
questions about substituting shell for
May because I think
May investigate is really way too
squishy and I think if the oversight
committee considers at which point
they must investigate I think that's the
nub of what you're talking about here
um and I don't know whether you would
want to delineate in statute you could
uh
the various levels of us an initial
screening and then and then the
difference between an informal
investigation and a formal investigation
I don't know if that's something that
people want to go into that level of
detail but I do think getting the word
shall in there at some level is is very
important that I
um
do take the counselor's point that
in terms of the public it's much more
helpful
to note that a complaint was made and
dismissed
then not knowing it was there at all and
but balancing that with
the public saying well that was a
terrible thing because they had a
terrible outcome
is is a tough one because there are
plenty of terrible outcomes where there
was no
um mistake or malpractice in terms of of
generally accepted
best practices it just didn't work out
the way you wanted it to
so I guess that's my bunch of comments I
representative soloway please respond uh
thank you representative that helps a
lot
um one of the issues that you raise that
kept me up at night quite literally that
in the drug
is that the way this is written there is
not a mechanism for solo practitioners
who don't belong to healthcare
organizations and I really didn't know
how to finesse that uh I don't have the
verbiage for it however in your wisdom
you have indicated that uh this may be a
recommendation for oversight as a
general area of concern and
consideration uh that uh should not
specify the contents of an LSR but it is
an area of for consideration and that
perhaps oversight can look at it and
remand it to a house committee on health
uh uh on
health and elderly Affairs Health Human
Services and not only Affairs
and likewise the same Committee in the
Senate but that's very helpful thank you
representative on this note I would like
to ask
um it should be the responsible
responsibility of any organization which
employs Physicians license to practice
in New Hampshire you do know I am
chairman of the board of one of those
yes however sir
um you do not have a solo practitioner
who is practicing outside an
organization
you you're a practitioner is within an
we have presently two pcps and are
hoping to replace the third one so is
would this language suggest that we
establish such an internal Review
Committee absolutely so then it would
possibly be the case that non-medical
people would conduct that review
that's an interesting question it would
certainly be the purview of the
organization itself to determine uh who
would be on their committees
so and it would very likely include
people who were not Physicians perhaps
as far afield as a cleric
um who believes in statues but not
statutes yes yeah
um
and
that might include
um Hollow statues
that you know that so but
there's a real question I mean how am I
going to set this up if this goes in the
way you've got it
well I my failure and I have thought
about this is what if you have a locally
practicing physician who is not a member
of an organization and therefore not
supervised by such a committee okay so
are they are they free and clear except
when except when there's a complaint
filed to the court
or whether they file a citizen complaint
to the Board of Medicine
so the whole issue of screening by a
hospital or Health Center committee
would not occur okay
in fact that's one of the concerns that
I have further down because we're back
to the who has jurisdiction to make a
complaint to the Board of Medicine it's
the clerk of the superior court or a
certain Committee in the hospital and I
would maintain that if the committee of
the hospital does not complain but
should have a physician in that hospital
or outside of that hospital should have
standing to make the complaint so there
needs to be a not you know it could
include but not limited to down in that
fourth paragraph perhaps
or could I suggest that we're making it
a little too complicated because
everybody has the right to complain now
and I think that we have heard that
there are issues of how much weight is
given to each particular entity who
complains but I would be very much
opposed to getting into any statute
which limited who may complain this
statute it seems to me should be
directed to who has a duty to complain
and I want to be very clear that nothing
that I have said addresses the issue
that representative salary raised which
is the solo practitioner that's going to
have to be for either others who
practice with them and that could
perhaps be other employees in their
practice although that's very
uncomfortable for the employees it could
certainly be patients who are great
grief and it probably would also be
colleagues who have seen the effects of
something that has gone wrong but in
those cases I don't see how you can
mandate an internal review of one by one
because I don't think that's going to be
very useful and
the issue raised by
chairman Pearson is one that perhaps
people might want to think about in
terms of the size of the organization
which is mandated to have some kind of
review although I would submit that if
you have an organization which employees
do
you probably have some kind of internal
reviews already we do and it's it's it
may not be a morbidity board but if you
have some kind of internal review then
you're then you're home free
um but I I think that um
again being too specific is going to run
afoul of
um
non-traditional practices of one sort or
another
and I'm also not sure whether we whether
this goes just Physicians or
um other Specialties as well that's
that's one question I would have but
um
I think it
is better framed in terms of concerns to
be pursued rather than an LSR to be
drafted
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative salary for taking this
stab at this um possible LSR I would
mention here that in the third paragraph
I think that
there's no question in my mind having
worked in hospital for many decades that
the Bad actors in a hospital those that
are not performing quality work unknown
to those that are working in the
hospital at all levels nurses Physicians
other Physicians
um Texan they are everybody knows who is
not performing well so that's where I
believe it should start and I think this
is basically identifying the hospital as
a spot where it should start
um
it probably would not be the
credentialing committees probably the
privileging Committees credentialing is
really where you realize somebody's has
a license or a college degree or
whatever privileging is where they come
up with the privileges in the hospital
itself and what they can and cannot do
m m conferences are protected by quality
assurance and therefore probably would
not be a source of this information but
what I would suggest is that there is a
mechanism in place in many hospitals
where the medical staff office which has
a president of the medical staff is
oftentimes the place where many
complaints from within the hospital are
actually funneled
in many hospitals also the medical staff
president actually reports directly to
the Board of Trustees and I think that's
an important point that they're not
responding they're not reporting to
leadership leadership has a different
lens sometimes in the hospital with
regard to the um the the workings of the
hospital where the trustees have a
fiduciary responsibility not only to the
organization but to the community and I
think that if the medical staff has the
direct link to the trustees then they
are the ones that can act in vis-a-vis
with my next point would be who does the
reporting to the Board of Medicine
I think it was evident to me in the CMC
and again that's only one example but
having said that those that have quote a
a very high earner say or somebody that
they do not want to in any way
compromise
oftentimes is less incentive to report
that person I'm not saying always but
they can be the case in those
circumstances and I think the trustees
may be the right vehicle by which any
complaints that come through the medical
staff office assess the individual or
the problem and then be the ones that
directly report to the Board of Medicine
um
in your second to last paragraph there I
think it would be the Board of Medicine
that regulates the licensing they don't
regulate privileges in for the providers
as well
and I appreciate this and I think it
gets at the heart of the matter in my
mind where the problem is first
identified and then who should do the
reporting and how should they get
information about what happens in a
hospital and I would argue that in many
places medical staff offices have that
direct Pipeline and they are solid lines
to the Board of Trustees maybe a dotted
line to the c-suite but again that would
be the line of you know of action that I
would take my two other suggestions here
that I was thinking about since this
does involve many of the operations in
workings of the hospital might it be
helpful to have the hospital Association
present to actually comment on what this
would mean as far as an organizational
shift within many of the hospitals
within the state
and also at the very end of this should
we potentially be adding if we're going
to present this to the committee in two
weeks or the end of next week should we
also be putting in some language about
transparency whether it is
um issues regarding if somebody is still
licensed if somebody is been suspended
their privileges revoked whatever that
may be that's on their website should we
identify things that we can use as
transparency issues including
potentially as in Vermont not far from
where I live that if you have a suit not
a suit that was any suit but a suit that
was actually
resolved in the favor of the plaintiff
or the patient within the last 10 years
it was listed as a case but not any
specific so again I was thinking about
adding other things in addition to your
good work right here as well
thank you
representative Murphy thank you
um I you and I agree thoroughly
on the role of the president of the
medical staff
um that's a great insight and I
appreciate that thank you
um you suggest that the president of the
medical staff has a reporting
relationship to the Board of Trustees
um
several of us here have walked Hospital
corridors
and been in boardrooms and I'm going to
ask you whether you think that the
members of a Board of Trustees would be
the most competent forum for
investigating challenges to uh
privileges
thank you for that question I'm not sure
that they would necessarily understand
potentially the credentialing and
privileging but I think it is their
responsibility as the ultimate governing
body of a hospital to be the ones that
have a significant fiduciary
responsibility not only to the hospital
but to the community and therefore they
should be in my mind as opposed to
others in any Hospital situation may
have a bias or a lens that
um
sometimes is clouded I think the
trustees in their role have the ultimate
responsibility and again this is a point
of discussion it was only brought up as
a suggestion but my other concern
besides identifying the fact that it is
clearly within the hospital that people
identify and know who is not performing
well my question and again I'm open to
anybody else's suggestion is how does
that information get to the Board of
Medicine to act upon
and I only I would only disagree with
one other point that was made previously
in my mind there is no frivolous lawsuit
because if you ask any physician any
lawsuit is a problem it's emotionally
and financially taxing so I I don't like
the word frivolous lawsuit because it is
not frivolous to The Physician or the PA
or the nurse practitioner that's at the
end of a Barb on that in that thing so
that's why I'm a bit cautious about
every lawsuit being aired into the open
because there are so many instances
where they are dismissed and that can be
a real problem for any practice and
physician to have a laundry list of
suits that were quote frivolous or
really not significant but they should
know that you had a lawsuit that
ultimately ended up in Damages to any
patient or individual and was
compensated as such so I would I would
not probably have every lawsuit open to
the public but I think those that are
egregious and those that public should
know about will be aired in the Board of
Medicine so thank you someone and you
know the stack is getting higher and
higher I think it may have been Board of
Medicine that gave me a chart starting
with
the smallest little yishuna
all the way up to you should be shot at
Sunrise and a lot of things in between
and the question is at what level do
those things become public it's I was
never a news but I uh newspapers but I
was on radio as a talk show host and I
know that a a story gets the big play
and the exoneration
gets little so let's not put it on
I am having a meeting with the board the
hospital Association later this week so
represent it to anybody over here
representative Edwards next
um thank you Mr chair as I'm as I'm
looking at this document I I'm I'm
seeing some headings that are popping
out and I like headings and we get into
uh the information flow from uh where
patient care is taking place getting it
to the Board of Medicine I think there
was a rough consensus that one of the
biggest things that we ought to try to
address is to make sure that the Board
of Medicine had more information because
we made the observation that you don't
know what you don't know and that we
wanted to make more things knowable so
the the information flow of this is a
pretty major paragraph and it's one of
the heavy lifts I think that we want to
be able to do second paragraph is on the
investigation part we've used word
screen informal formal investigations
and the status of the things what you
know but and I I think it may already be
in the statute but it would be worth
looking at again just to make sure that
we're clear on the semantics around
investigations
the third big paragraph is the is kind
of the determination step for the Board
of Medicine you know what what once they
have this investigation completed they
need to determine whether or not it's
reportable or not and and you just
mentioned sir that there's probably this
big long list of
transactions and and we probably need to
draw the line uh in that somewhere
saying these are reportable these are
not kind of thing just just for clarity
and then the last paragraph I think
starts to hit on Manpower Manpower and
money and and and so uh Miss Haynes had
a suggestion we may want to consider or
or not just throw it to the general
court to staff at nor to fund it I don't
know but but that's a whole separate
section is the Manpower and money part
of this I I did if you'll let me go on
just a little longer have a question
about
um
the information flow Miss Haynes had
mentioned something that I don't think
is in this paragraph four that maybe we
missed and that is she talked about how
all malpractice is reported to some
National Database and simultaneously
those malpractice notifications get sent
to the boards of medicine and I see the
last sentence of this paragraph saying
the clerk of the superior court is
likewise directed to report to the Board
of Medicine I I don't know if that's
sufficient I don't know if that captures
what Miss Haynes was saying in terms of
who is generating the malpractice
information I I just don't remember
testimony well enough and she had to
leave do you remember
let me just finish the thought and then
I'll come back
um okay so I I don't know if we've got a
sufficient who in addition to the clerk
of superior court and then this sentence
sort of trails off it says that uh the
the you know there shall any any
judicial finding and malpractice which
comes before it and which results in a
finding a malpractice well what what are
we going to do with those are we are we
going to is this is this what we're
saying we're going to investigate those
or or we by definition going to report
them I I think there's some clarity
around the malpractice issue that I'm
going to say that I'm not sure that that
is standing is correct I think doesn't
the clerk of the Superior Court have to
report to the Board of Medicine when
there is a filing of a lawsuit does it
have to actually be adjudicated before
or not counselors
I believe so and I believe there was
testimony last time due to the fact that
settlements outside of Corps aren't
reported to the board but once it gets
to once they get to court so it doesn't
have to be which results in a finding of
malpractice it's the mere bringing of
the suit into the court system
yes I'll admit I I could be completely
wrong what I could have sworn I heard I
want to nail this one down before we
but that's my recollection of the
testimony
um yeah mine too I want to be careful
about it
you have raised a very interesting issue
if one comes before the court
and defends against an allegation of
malpractice
and is found not guilty of malpractice
would it not be within American
jurisprudence that a finding of not
guilty does not require reporting to the
Board of Medicine
foreign
off your phrase this provision shall
stand along current practice
I don't believe this is current practice
but you list in the next two lines I
just want to make sure maybe it should
be but I'm not sure it is a
representative Weber well without
getting into the very specifics because
we are going to get bogged down in the
weeds with all the little
details that we can explore
my mind I think was working very much
along the same lines as representative
Edwards and I came up with five headings
which was and the questions rather than
prescriptions one is at what level
must something be reported
who reports it
how was it investigated
and then what gets reported to the
public at what level do you report to
the public and I I I'm not ready to make
answers to any of those questions and
then the fifth peace is the Manpower and
the money for the investigations which
is is sort of a separate thing but if we
look at them at at those and if we look
at them as
the threshold for a mandate
and we reserve
the right of everybody to report if if
you know if I've got a hangnail and I'm
upset about it I can report it but the
board's probably not going to do
anything about it and that's as it
should be
um if you it seems to me that for
transparency what we're trying to do is
set the level at which information must
come to the board first
secondly who gets that information to
the board because it may be very
different in different organizations
third how the board is going to
investigate so I think number five
actually is a subset of number three is
does the board need
um a professional structure to do that
with
and then finally at what level is
um
an event reported to the problem an
event and an outcome reported to the
public
um so that that doesn't get us any
farther forward making actual decisions
about
where we're going to set those bars but
it's kind of a framework to work in
attorney Esther Hutch you had your name
hand up yes uh yes Mr thank you for
recognizing me I know we didn't get too
much into the Weeds about how oplc
functions and operates in this committee
but I I want to remind everyone that the
committee that came about because of SB
330 has also been meeting and in that
there were recommendations I haven't
seen any lsrs I haven't seen any written
language drafted language yet but there
were recommendations
around
the authority in regards of who has the
responsibility between oplc and the
boards as to who should be investigating
claims from the public so that is a
thing that the SB 330 subcommittee is
also taking a look at right now and then
the last paragraph As far as the the
funding piece uh I didn't come prepared
to speak on funding and I'm not an
expert but I I do have a a general sense
of how things work but the boards don't
receive individual funding oplc does not
receive funding from the general funds
we oversee 54 boards and the
administrative services that we provide
um pursuant to 310 A1 and the rest of it
come about due to the licensing fees and
oplc has the fee setting Authority for
the boards and that is also something
that the SB 330 subcommittee is taking a
hard look at right now so I just before
we get too far in the investigation
piece the funding piece I wanted to make
the the subcommittee here today aware of
sort of what's going on with 330 and how
in a general sense oplc is funded and
operates
the chair wonders if anyone on the
committee has done a comparison to how
this very issue is handled in other
states
a wheel inventing can be made easier
that representative Pearson yes
um I feel obligated to answer that
because I want to uh OLS and got all
that research and got the digital copies
made and distributed the digital copies
and and I I did not keep reading through
them to do my own compare and contrast
but as you may recall from when I
introduced that digital copy it was said
to me by the person who did the research
that his perception was that that Maine
looked like they were kind of an they
were an exemplary State and and I I I
must admit that I've not dug into that
statement any further than that
okay
Mr Potter would you like to come up
James Potter from the New Hampshire
Medical Society
former second string quarterback at the
University of Michigan
it is college football season we got to
give you your shout out the Patriots are
looking sir
thank you very much
if you would be so kind as to turn your
mic on please thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh I appreciate that but I
think uh Bailey as happy is doing a
crippled job for the Patriots right now
coming off the bench but thank you for
the record my name is Jim Potter I Am
The Executive Vice President and CEO of
the New Hampshire Medical Society so I
wanted we were actually planning to
testify on your hearing on the 31st when
I'm kind of hearing or taking up is you
may not meeting on the 31st and I do
apologize I've been out last couple
weeks on a personal matter out of town
so I knew I wasn't going to be able to
have written testimony in specific
testimony for you but I can draw to a
couple points if if I could from the
discussion today by the way I think both
are ourselves and I think the hospital
Association was uh intending to testify
on the 31st the hospital Association is
actually at its annual meeting today so
they're kind of precluded from from
testifying today number one
um
I think what representative Murphy
and representative whoever had good
ideas with the proposal that you put
forth uh representative Subway I
appreciate this but um I I would take I
would have the hospital Association
closely review this and I'd like
representative whoever's idea to pose
this to them in a series of questions
um to my my general knowledge current
statutes already require hospitals to
report actions taken by uh taken against
Physicians to the Board of Medicine and
then the Board of Medicine investigates
so that's just one clarification but I I
think taking your proposal you will
probably learn that many of the things
that you're proposing are already in
policy for the hospital Association but
they can clarify most the best and I
don't want to yeah point before you go
um sir hospitals are required for are
certain actions to be reported to the
bom can that be blocked in other words
can the appropriate reporting Committee
in the hospital
decide that well this doesn't really
rise to the level of
and so it doesn't get reported but
several physicians in the hospital
perhaps might be saying oh yes it does
so does this block it out or may those
physicians in their own person
report uh thank you for the question I
think it's a great question I'm not sure
what the standard is but I'm sure that
the hospital associate can tell you
specifically what that standard is that
would require reporting so I think it's
important you talk to them bring that
forward
a second I think there's a
a general misunderstandings and uh
incorrect inferences about the Board of
Medicine and how volunteer it is
um as I kind of heard uh attorney Heinz
mentioned she talked about a process
that works for attorneys generally as I
heard it I said that's the same exact
process or very close to it that's taken
on by professional staff through oplc
that includes you know a a physician
investigator that includes investigators
that includes a medical review
subcommittee and so now you're not alone
nor is anybody else on the throne about
you know looking at the board of
medicines processes
I'm fairly new here I've been here seven
years but when I witnessed early on in
my tenure here was
Physicians free freezing up when they
got that letter from the Board of
Medicine literally freezing themselves
out of the first couple steps of the
process and so having to go to an
automatic full review hearing by the
entire Ward which is was very lengthy
and that concerned me
so I think it's important to clarify
here that when Physicians get this
letter this is one of the most
traumatizing things that they'll go
through albeit losing a patient
you know so I realized that and we saw
some some funding to try to clarify that
through the Federation and State Medical
boards they turned down our fundering
question that I went back to our
foundation and said would you fund a
continuing medical education project
that goes and teaches Physicians
very much about this process and I'm
pleased to tell you that that is
actually coming to four
um it was supposed to start at our our
annual meeting at the end of this month
but because of the notoriety of the the
case that was in the newspapers we've
had several medical staff say can you
can we already get this and so we're
doing it early I think we have at least
a couple before uh the next couple weeks
that we're coming in so this is a hour
and a half program that goes in and
talks about you know essentially the
investigative process the complaint the
disciplinary process to really help so
we're committed to that kind of
transparency because a lot of people and
I heard a lot of testimony today that
confirmed that you know a lot of people
really don't know about those processes
and so we think that's an important
thing
um to move forward and at some point if
this group or anybody else wants to to
hear you know to see this you can come
to our annual meeting uh I'll give you
all free passes to that uh to hear that
um that that discussion
um uh the uh other thing I want to make
and this would preview our testimony on
the 31st is that we will be giving
testimony that no England uh State Board
of Medicine reports much of what the
plaintiff's bar
um uh testified to today such as
complaints file the legend malpractice
in accord complaints filed with the
Board of Medicine that do not result in
disciplinary proceedings
um and then the results of number two uh
that I just mentioned so again I think
that's what we'd be focusing on a little
bit more
um and again I it's it's my fault that I
wasn't here for the last couple of these
meetings but that's what we would focus
on the 31st and I think the the hospital
Association could focus on uh if if
you're willing focus on probably give
you some very in-depth information on on
what you put forth to representative
Solway
which I hope that's that's somewhat
helpful
any questions from Mr Prada when when is
your meeting I go to a lot of medical
meetings but when is yours ours is uh
that previous weekend uh the 28th 29th
and 30th
um okay uh but if you'd like to
um but we could also arrange that we
could we could do something for you that
you know if you wanted to do this in a
zoom call or something like this but I
think because of this issue I think it's
important for individuals to kind of
understand the process and not make
inferences or assumptions about it is I
heard a lot going on today
any questions
tomorrow
none thank you so much thank you very
much
Mr or doctor or attorney or
doctor okay
come on up
turn the mic on
speaker run
yeah all right very primitive yeah David
Wagner I'm at it I've been a physician
in the state for 40 years now
so a little closer to the mic for those
whose ears are old
um
I wasn't planning on testifying today
but you seem to have some confusion here
about what
um hospitals need to report
to the Board of Medicine
um and the proposal that you were the
guys have been talking about there is an
RSA 151 6. B
uh on the books already which pretty
clearly delineates the hospital's
responsibilities
uh you know it's basically reporting of
this party action every facility
administrator or does it me or any other
health care facility places into this
chapter shall report to the Board of
Medicine
any disciplinary action or adverse
action within 30 days
um there's another doctor that I have my
hands here that's from the Board of
Medicine website that has guidelines for
Hospital reporting and this was
effective in September 9 2001.
um that's right on the website
the Board of Medicine website and it
basically is a summary of what should be
reported and what should not be reported
and it goes into a fair amount of detail
and it kind of goes over what's uh
what um at what level Things become
reportable to the Board of Medicine and
what isn't
is at least who this was this was
published by an approved by the Board of
Medicine on August 7 2002. let me
re-clarify my question you gave us what
may be reported does it say who may
report
every facility administrator or designee
for any health care facility
shell report
it gives no statue
no privileges to General citizens or no
just as it needs to be reported
these are must reports this is the
hospital must report the following thank
you all right and perhaps you'd like to
I should submit this to you the true
let's see the uh humiliations
thank you
thank you very much and Mr chair I think
we looked at that statute a bit in our
first meeting I think we did too and
again we we have the issue of
who must and who may
well here we are now what guys
Where Do We Go From Here We redraft
we redraft how do you propose we redraft
well we could have a subcommittee of the
subcommittee
we actually could have a subcommittee of
the subcommittee to redraft
I'm looking at flow here even if we meet
two weeks from today on October 31st
that will be after oversight meeting
which is on the 28th
um not come up till our November meeting
it in the November meeting which will be
the third Friday of November I believe
that may be after the LSR filing period
Council says no
it starts I believe the deadline the
last day is the 22nd oh
of November but I haven't checked the
calendar to be sure so so on this issue
we could have a
subcommittee of the subcommittee to come
up with
the second iteration of the
recommendation based on what we've heard
and we could look on that on the 31st
and it would go to oversight on whatever
the third Friday of November is and
still make the deadline for an LSR I
haven't looked at the calendar but the
deadline is the 22nd so it's possible
that it won't make the deadline too well
Mr chairman hang on one second the third
Friday of November is the 18th okay then
you then you're golden the other thing
to remember is of course that it's it's
not a it's not a committee that files an
lrsr it's individual legislators so but
I suspect the sponsor and many if not
all of the co-sponsors would be us and
it would be we excuse me um and uh
also members of oversight
Mr chairman I would point out that if we
follow the advice of Representative
Weber and we remove from the draft
verbiage regarding an LSR
but pose this as a proposal for
consideration
on the part of the oversight committee
that it would have and if we're
modest in our goals
that we would have a reasonable chance
of passing emotion at oversight whereas
if we make it highly specific and use
the language of lsrs we're going to get
mired as representative Weber says in
the weeds
so we can avoid the weeds and avoid
using Roundup at the same time it must
be specific enough not to be mush but
broad enough
not to overdo I suspect we could rely on
the subcommittee of the subcommittee to
do the draft
representative soloway who would you
suggest
I would suggest yourself sir
representative Edwards
I would certainly be glad to work with
you
and additional members as you choose
well I see two people in there who have
doctorates neither of whom the
doctorates are in medicine
may I may I suggest uh representative
Weber as an alternative to me and the
reason for that is uh she and I both
thought of the headlines uh or the
headings that we should use I I thought
hers were more complete and I like her
idea of posing questions so she's got an
insight into this that I think we want
are you willing to serve crap
um
I I have to say that right now
um I am dealing with
uh two family crises of The Sibling kind
and one family crisis of the canine kind
so if the question is today my answer is
no but certainly I would I would be glad
to be consulted and and
work on that and particularly
if we could you know if you don't
appoint a subcommittee official
subcommittee that would then be subject
to the right to no long way you know we
were less than a quorum we could just
informally submit a draft to each other
and then bring it back to this committee
or wherever else anybody wants to send
it there were nine people in this
subcommittee one of whom is absent so we
can have four what Dr Murphy like to be
part of it
all I'm saying is if you
establish a further official
subcommittee of a subcommittee of a
subcommittee it's subject to the right
to no law and I'm suggesting therefore
we may have up to four people because
this is a subcommittee of nine right
that's correct
so given the fact that uh we
informally have a JD a demon and a PhD
and wouldn't it be cool to have an MD on
this
you know it's about medicine
happy to serve thank you
everybody sneak off you have snuck off
successfully
now should we meet again on the 31st as
we have been advertising
well it sounds to me like we've got a
number of people who haven't commented
yet who are very much interested in the
process who we ought to hear from
and again we've got the time
to take into account their comments so I
think it would be a better thing to
operate with more of more information
rather than less
you know I'm not a minimalist
more is better yeah okay
all right so we will meet again one
o'clock Monday October 31st we hope here
the subcommittee of Representatives
soloway Pearson Weber and Murphy will
word Smith
and meanwhile I will be talking with the
hospital Association and see if perhaps
a few more of us could be invited to
that little Zoom Gathering
and I think that's it unless anybody
else has anything
all right motion to adjourn second all
right in favor I